it could be a defining week for New York
the coming days might be the worst yet
for America's hardest hit city more than
4,000 people have now died in the state
and the death toll is rising quickly I
think we all know that we have to reach
a certain point and that point is going
to be a horrific point in terms of death
but it's also a point at which things
are going to start changing we're
getting very close to that level right
now and the next week and a half two
weeks are gonna be I think they're gonna
be very difficult there is no avoiding
what's coming the government is now
reading the nation for the worst the
next week is going to be our Pearl
Harbor moment it's going to be our 9/11
moment it's going to be the hardest
moment for many Americans in their
entire lives and we really need to
understand that if we want to flatten
that curb and get through that to the
other side everyone needs to do their
part New York is fast reaching crunch
point it is right now in the thick of
the crisis if you look at this three-day
roll as opposed to day-to-day you could
argue that you're seeing a plateauing
but they want to find out they want the
future data to determine if this was a
plateau so in other words next week
they'll tell you after they have a few
days whether we're on a plateau or was
just a blip as New York is reaching the
top of the mountain other states are
still climbing it death rates are rising
across America but it's what happens
here in this city that will set the pace
for the rest of the country for weeks
the hospitals have been preparing the
governor's been preparing the National
Guard has been preparing and of course
New Yorkers have been preparing we'll
know soon whether they've done enough
the weekend sunshine briefly lifted the
gloom but there are dark days ahead for
this city New York and America is
bracing for what comes next
Alastor bundle Sky News New York